[Musique]
la crise du coc vide a plongé l'économie
dans la détresse
partout le chômage monte et les
populations du globe perdre tout du
pouvoir d'achat tout
non car un petit groupe de riches
résiste encore et toujours à la
précarité
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme le
rapport de oxfam sur les inégalités et
le co vide qui est sorti il ya quelques
semaines un vrai brûlot qui dresse un
constat alarmant sur les effets de la
crise actuelle
depuis mars et l'apparition du coc vide
les 10 hommes les plus riches du monde
aurait engrangé près de 540 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
largement de quoi mettre en place un bon
plan de relance ou une méga campagne de
vaccination dans le monde entier
pour ce qui est des français ils ont
engrangé 175 milliards entre mars et
décembre dépassant leurs niveaux d'avant
crise comme si rien ne s'était passé
cocorico du coup non m'a pas vraiment
parce que de l'autre côté du miroir
selon oxfam
la crise du coville devrait fait
basculer près de 1 million de français
supplémentaires dans la pauvreté
le nombre de bénéficiaires de l'aide
alimentaire atteignait en automne 2020
millions de personnes contre 5 5
millions l'année précédente
il en est de même pour le nombre de
bénéficiaires du rsa qui auraient bondi
de 8,5 pour cent par rapport à l'automne
2010 neuf et ça touche aussi l'épargnant
puisque les 20 % des français les plus
pauvres ont vu leur épargne diminué de
près de 2 milliards d'euros pendant le
premier confinement à leur coût 10 % des
français les plus riches
voyez pour leur fortune augmenter de
plus de 25 milliards d'euros
des chiffres qui ne risque pas de
s'arranger quand on sait que sur le
fameux plan de relance du gouvernement à
100 milliards à peine 1% est consacrée à
la lutte contre la pauvreté